public sénat france 24 et rfi présente
[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
pour ici l'europe depuis le 1er janvier
pour six mois c'est le portugal qui a
pris la présidence tournante de l'union
européenne
avec un agenda chargé sur le front
pandémique économique alors que l'europe
se re confine à grande vitesse et se
vaccine au ralenti voilà pourquoi nous
rejoignons aujourd'hui en duplex de
lisbonne augusto santos silva bonjour
vous êtes le ministre des affaires
étrangères du portugal
vous avez été aussi ministre de la
culture des affaires parlementaires de
la défense et donc des affaires
étrangères à partir de 2015 dans le
gouvernement d'union de la gauche
dirigée par antonio costa alors il se
trouve que vous prenez la succession
d'une présidence allemande qui a été
particulièrement efficace sur sur des
dossiers difficiles le les fonds de
relance le budget européen le brésil
c'est la coordination européenne pour
l'achat des vaccins et vous vouliez
mettre vous votre présidence puisque c
est un gouvernement socialiste sous le
signe de l'europe sociale
et maintenant quelle est votre priorité
des priorités en ces temps difficiles à
la priorité des priorités c'est la
relance et pour faire la relance il faut
améliorer notre réponse sanitaire ou un
après-midi alors je dirais que c'est la
priorité la plus urgente est la prise
importante parce que il faut mettre sur
le terrain les instruments financiers
dont vous avez déjà parlé le fond de la
relance
oui le budget pluriannuel pour ce faire
il faut accélérer le processus des
ratifications nationales des décisions
prises par l'union européenne au cours
de 2020 et puis il faut accélérer aussi
le processus de vaccination de notre
population parce que c'est une condition
nécessaire pour la relance
alors votre pays le portugal est
actuellement très frappé par cette
deuxième vague l'un des pays les plus
infectés au monde alors que vous aviez
été épargné par la première vague
aujourd'hui les autorités sanitaires
reproche à votre gouvernement d'avoir
été trop permissif cet été pendant les
dernières fêtes pour sauver le tourisme
l'économie
qu'est ce que vous avez à répondre ce
qu'il ya eu une erreur de votre part le
fait c'est que le portugal qui s'est
création très proche avec le royaume uni
est un des pays européens
maintenant le plus le plus frappé par
l'habitation britannique dee virus et ça
explique en tout ce sont des cas qui ont
été découverts au portugal les derniers
jours bien bientôt bien sûr il ya aussi
un effet et des fêtes de noël on a pris
la décision de fermer les écoles toutes
les écoles à tous les niveaux pendant
une quinzaine pour éviter la
contamination du virus
alors je crois que janvier va être moi
très difficile peut être février sera
aussi un mois dur mais avec la
progression de la vaccination et avec
les effets des mesures de confinement
bon on espère que pendant le printemps
mais choses se calment et jusqu'à la fin
de l'été on peut vacciner
plus de la moitié des portugais adultes
alors que le groupe puisse se produire
jeudi soir se tenait à bruxelles en
visioconférence un sommet européen sur
la lutte coordonnée contre la pandémie
il n'a pas été décidé de tests pcr
harmonisées pour voyager entre les pays
européens
pour le moment l'allemagne elle demande
plus elles veulent harmonisation totale
des ouvertures de commerces des mesures
de confinement alors vers qu'il faut
tendre finalement non ce qui concerne
les mesures de confinement ce qui
concerne les mesures de restrictions sur
la circulation des personnes des genres
il faut être coordonné c'est celle à une
priorité le deuxième priorité c'est
d'accélérer le processus de vaccination
bien sûr ce vaccin a été celui qui est
le plus vite produit et distribué dans
l'histoire de la vaccination universelle
on ne doit pas oublier ça et le
processus d'achat conjointe de toute
l'europe a été vraiment un fait très
important pour l'efficacité de notre
vaccination dont tous les états membres
à mon espère que l' agence du médicament
européenne puisse approuver le nouveau
de novaxel celui qui a été développé par
l'université d'oxford par astra zeneca
parce que ça permettra changer d'échelle
précisément sur la vaccination c'est
vrai que les vingt-sept ont choisi de
déléguer à la commission le fait de
passer la commande des vaccins mais on
voit aujourd'hui que certains pays font
cavalier seul c'est le cas par exemple
de la hongrie qui s'apprête à passer des
commandes du vaccin russe le spoutnik v
est ce que c'est vraiment autorisé et
quelles sont les conséquences et ce que
encore une fois l'europe se retrouve
divisé
je crois que l'école les conséquences
seront négatives pour voir en elle même
nous sommes tous les états membres du
moins 26,6 aux 27 états membres
nous sommes engagés dans un processus
d'achat conjointe et ce processus
d'achat conjointe c'est vraiment
important pour nous tous et ceux qui
essaient de trouver un channel un
parcours un chemin alternative au chemin
de la coopération européenne
je crois que ils n'auront pas de chance
ils ne sont pas gagnants parce que c'est
le plus efficace moyen le plus efficace
que nous avons en europe pour accélérer
la vaccination gratuite universelle de
tous les gens c'est l'effort européen
là aussi on dit est ce que est ce qu'on
a commandé à c est ce que finalement ça
correspond à des commandes de la
commission déficiente livraison des
industriels trop lente parce que si on
veut vraiment protéger 70% des adultes
fin août on n'a pas le rythme qu'il faut
partout en europe mais le problème c'est
pas le nombre des vaccins qui ont été
commandés on a commandé plus d'un
milliard de vaccins et nous avons en 460
millions de personnes habitent en europe
le problème c'est que évidemment on ne
produit pas un milliard de vaccins sur
l'instant et on a remis ni strap à 1
milliards de vaccins sur l'instant alors
ça prend du temps il faut préserver tous
les mesures de groupes de réflexion tous
les mesures sanitaires de protection
pendant que la vaccination se fait alors
c'est vrai que ces vaccinations elle
suscite des polémiques de tous ordres et
notamment aussi parmi la population il
ya encore pas mal de défiance à l'égard
de ces vaccins parce qu'ils sont
totalement nouveau des technologies
révolutionnaires qui n'ont jamais été
utilisés sur des hommes jusqu'à
maintenant
la france est en tête des vaccinaux
sceptiques avec 46% encore de sceptiques
d'où le succès des uns fox sur les
vaccins mathilde bénézet passe au crible
l'une des fausses nouvelles qui
circulent le plus sur les réseaux
sociaux en europe
bill gates va t'il nous implanter des
puces 5 g avec le vaccin contre la
colite 19
de nombreux internautes accusent le
philanthrope américain d'avoir créé ce
virus pour prendre le contrôle de la
population en injectant des puce de
géo-localisation 5g via ces vaccins et
les célébrités ne semble pas immunisés
contre ces théories complotistes en mai
dernier l'actrice française juliette
binoche suivi par plus de 300 mille
abonnés sur instagram postes sur son
compte
ce sont des opérations organisées par
des groupes financiers internationaux
principalement américains depuis
longtemps ils manipulent sans être
parano les vaccins qu'ils préparent en
font partie
mettre une puce sous cutanée pour tous
ces non non aux opérations de bill gates
non à la 5g c'est évidemment faux
cette théorie du complot mélange trois
différentes initiatives financées par la
fondation gates la recherche d'un vaccin
contre la copie 19 pour laquelle bill
gates a fait don de 250 millions de
dollars depuis le début de la pandémie
le programme digital heidi 2020 qui vise
à offrir aux personnes sans papiers une
carte d'identité et un carnet de santé
numérique et des recherches du hem haïti
pour le développement de vaccins
injectant une ancre dans la peau comme
un tatouage cette encre lisibles
uniquement grâce à une lumière
infrarouge permettrait de savoir qui a
été vaccinées ou non
mais ces trois projets n'ont pour
l'instant absolument aucun rapport entre
eux par ailleurs il est techniquement
impossible d'injecter un traceur gps via
un vaccin
aucune technologie de géolocalisation ne
peut fonctionner sans l'aide d'une
grosse batterie à recharger réguler
man a moins de s'accrocher une énorme
batterie autour du cou c'est tout
simplement irréalisable
we do santos silva comment lutter contre
ces un fox est ce que vous avez une
proposition à nous faire pourquoi pas ce
que le dirigeant et requins peut-être
pourrait donner l'exemple en se faisant
vacciner
oui mais bien sûr et on fait en il faut
lutter contre ces mensonges avec les
instruments typiquement européen la
raison la science les expertises et il
faut évidemment que les hommes les
femmes politiques mais aussi les médias
s'engage dans une communication publique
stratégique pour montrer que les accents
sont toutes à tout à fait totalement
confiance dans prise hier je crois la
majorité des états membres dans le
portugal les gens ont une anxiété parce
que pour elle la vaccination devrait
être immédiate
alors il n'y a pas une défiance
anxiété parce que tout le monde voulait
être vaccinés aussi tôt possible alors
les européens
c'est un chapitre diplomatique
évidemment qui vous intéressent au plus
haut point ont salué l'arrivée de joe
biden à la maison blanche
outre atlantique keira réintégrer
immédiatement l'accord de paris sur le
climat l'union européenne veut
d'ailleurs lui pas proposer un nouveau
pacte fondateur transatlantique mais sur
le commerce sur la présence dans l'otan
est ce que byden ne va pas marcher un
petit peu discrètement dans les pas de
donald trump
je crois pas que l'arrivée de joe
maidana la maison blanche souvent
blanches se représente aussi une relance
une autre relance la relance de
l'alliance et heroes américaine la
relance de la relation très proche entre
l'union européenne et les etats unis à
ce niveau l'administration trempe a été
l'exception la règle c'est à un très bon
dialogue entre l'europe et les états
unis ndt il en plus sur des thèmes qui
sont des thèmes difficiles alors je
bouge j'espère deux choses j'espère que
les américains nous nous rejoignent sur
le plan de l'assise unis sur le plan
l'action de la clématite sur le plan du
développement soutenable de la
coopération avec les pays en train de
développement mais j'espère aussi
deuxième chose que sur les les aspects
difficiles dont la taxation des grandes
entreprises technologiques numériques et
le commerce où il y a des difficultés où
il y a des divergences entre
l'europe et les états unis ces
divergences puisse être adressées d'une
façon moins agressive alors nos amis
américains
ils ont envie effectivement de renouer
avec l'europe mais ils sont très
sensibles sur la question de la chine
or les européens ont signé le 30
décembre quelques jours avant
l'investiture de joe biden un accord
d'investissement avec la chine
assez controversé critiqué par les
conseillers de joe biden et on sait vous
êtes bien placé pour le savoir que les
américains n'aiment pas trop les
investissements chinois en europe
notamment chez vous ils n'ont pas envie
que les chinois investissent
construisent le port de sines alors quel
est le point d'équilibré
permettez moi de dire qu'il ya aussi des
foetus sur l'investissement étranger au
portugal les chinois n'ont pas construit
le port de sines le port dessinait
existe depuis je crois une cinquantaine
de l'année il est la propriété de l'état
portugais t il
il est dirigé par une compagnie de
singapour
maintenant sur la question des accords
entre
hop et la chine c'est un accord de
principe il faut travailler il faut
travailler avec du temps avec deux
soucis avec la la profondeur analyse
analytique qui est nécessaire et la
présidence portugaise va le faire avec
la commission et le parlement européen
pour que les choses soient claires
monsieur ministre sur le plan
diplomatique alors autre grand sujet
quand même du moment l'opposant russe
alexeï navalni a survécu en allemagne à
son empoisonnement il est courageusement
rentrer en russie incarcéré il est
devenu une figure face à poutine pour
l'europe
or cette union européenne elle a besoin
du gaz russe est elle prête à prendre
davantage de sanctions pour favoriser la
démocratie russe nous avons déjà vu
demandez-le à la libération de monsieur
la vanille on a critiqué son arrêt à
face à son arrivée à moscou et nous
espérons que les autorités d'un riche
comprennent l'importance de respecter
les droits fondamentaux de monsieur la
vanille comprennent aussi la question
vraiment politique qui se posent à ce
moment parce que il n'ya pas de
démocratie n'a pas d'état de droit si
vous ne respectez pas les droits
fondamentaux de l'individu ce ne
permettait pas que le boxing
l'opposition puisse s'exprimer
alors un an tant ils ne répondent plus à
la demande
enoh espérant que cette réponse soit
positive
merci à vous d'avoir été en notre
compagnie vous restez bien sûr sur notre
antenne dans la seconde partie nous
revenons sur ce thème des fêtes news des
fausses nouvelles et de la réponse
européenne
quand ma camarade de
senna mort a rejoint sur ce plateau
s'est tout de suite
[Musique]
bienvenue au parlement européen pour
notre débat combien avez-vous partager
deux tweets like émoticônes cette
semaine notre vie quotidienne et sociale
est désormais envahis par les réseaux
sociaux encore plus sollicité en plein
confinement pandémique mais font-ils le
bien et concours t-il à la bonne santé
de notre mental et de nos démocraties
l'union européenne s'en méfient en tout
cas et hausse le ton à travers le
digital services act présenté le 15
décembre par la commission
il incite les plateformes regroupement
plus de 45 millions d'utilisateurs tels
google facebook twitter youtube à
modérer leur contenu pour lutter contre
la haine virtuel alors faute de
régulation outre atlantique
twitter facebook youtube et cetera ont
coupé l'accès à ses comptes à donald
trump
après l'insurrection contre le capitole
mettant fin à quatre années d'outrance
sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est une première qui fait d'ailleurs
polémique ici mais aussi de l'autre côté
de l'atlantique pour en débattre nous
avons invité deux eurodéputés
aujourd'hui fabienne keller bonjour
dénichées aux réunions donc le parti
présidentiel en france la france qui a
introduit d'ailleurs un amendement sur
les réseaux sociaux pour une modération
plus strict des contenus illicites et de
plus lourd deux amendes et puis nous
sommes face aujourd'hui à sas car
bricmont bonjour députée européenne
belge pour les verts qui s'inquiète
effectivement d'une possible censure
d'une législateur on va en parler
mesdames pour qu'on prenne bien vos
positions de départ
en quelques mots est ce que vous êtes
pour légiférer pour contraindre les
réseaux sociaux ou doivent-ils mieux
s'autoréguler sask abric mans je pense
qu'il est essentiel de réguler l'action
particulièrement des plateformes
monopolistique un don qui sont cinq
grandes plateformes les guerres femmes
qui aujourd'hui ont le monopole et il
faut absolument les réguler parce que ce
qu'on a vu dans le cas de trains p puis
à d'autres exemples mais le 4ème paix
quand même emblématique
il n'appartient pas aussi aux deux
plateformes privées de décider quelle
est la parole légitime ou pas et de
décider un moment donné de réguler un
espace public selon des considérations
plateformes privées et puis cette
décision a été prise dans un contexte
sans doute trop tardif aussi au moment
où les démocrates sont en majorité et
peut-être avec un cadre régulatoire
ça aurait pu être fait avant fabienne
keller pour ou contre une législation la
matière il est clair qu'il faut que
l'europe encadre ce qui circule sur les
réseaux sociaux sur les outils
numériques tout le monde y ait accès les
petits et les grands
certains de ces contenus sont
particulièrement violents l'europe vient
d'ailleurs d'avoir une avancée force sur
les contenus terroristes cela il ya un
accord sur le principe du fait qu'ils
doivent être retirés et le texte sera
adopté le mois prochain
donc nous avançons en la commission
propose d'encadrer les contenus illégaux
mais il nous faut un débat parce qu'il
faut un bon équilibre entre protection
contre des contenus dangereux haine qui
se diffusent de manière très très
horizontale et puis cette protection
qu'on doit à tout le monde et le
caractère même dangereux parce qu'on
voit que plus les tweets les messages
sont violents et plus il se diffuse vite
a enregistré réseaux sociaux sont aussi
un outil qui est très utilisé par les
extrémistes voire les complotistes ou
ceux qui défendent ils ont américains
parce que quatre ans de tweaks liban
festif un appel sur les réseaux sociaux
à marcher sur le capitole pour ses
partisans symbole de la démocratie
américaine tout de même des comptes du
président couper d'un seul coup d'un
seul
quelle leçon pour nous les européens
alors donald trump s'est vraiment
l'homme du populisme des mots chocs
violents des appels antidémocratique
clairement appelé à marcher contre le
capitole ne pas condamner clairement une
fois que les manifestants sont à
l'intérieur au prix de 5 vit quand même
donc on est sur quelque chose
extrêmement violent l'europe doit
pouvoir légiférer pour éviter cela on
est dans une grande liberté aux états
unis et des excès qui ne sont pas
régulés donald trump qui a pratiqué une
forme de politique qui est intolérable
qui n'est pas la politique pour débat d
idées mais où ces chocs contre choc
je crois que l'europe ne veut pas se
laisser entraîner en tout cas nous
portons une vision plus apaisée plus
respectueuse de l'autre des échanges en
politique parce qu'il n'est pas légitime
selon vous pour un réseau social et des
patrons de géants numérique de décidé de
censurer des milliers d'utilisateurs
même si c'est au nom de la lutte contre
la violence
effectivement il faut un cadre légal
d'abord et que les décisions soient
prises par le pouvoir judiciaire pour
moi c'est essentiel et c'est sans doute
là aussi qu' on peut diverger dans les
points de vue puisque certains groupes
politiques portent la proposition de de
donner la possibilité aux plateformes
d'accéder au contenu de nos
conversations privées aussi pour le
retrait notamment de contenus tels que
le contenu terroristes et là on dit
attention attention aux libertés
fondamentales parce que toucher aux
conversations privées au contenu privé
c'est comme toucher au courrier postal
ce serait autorisé la poste d'ouvrir
notre courrier et ça aujourd'hui c'est
interdit et donc il faut aussi appliquer
au monde digital des règles qui
protègent les données fondamentales tout
en luttant contre les propos haineux et
xénophobes
les appels à la violence et tout ce qui
peut être liberticide et problématiques
aussi tout ce qui est concerne le
harcèlement enfin en ligne
ce sont des tendances que l'on que l'on
voit d'autant plus fortement aujourd'hui
que nous sommes confinés et que le monde
digital a finalement envahi les maisons
aussi donc il y a vraiment un cadre
public à y mettre et des normes par
exemple par rapport aux algorithmes
faire en sorte qu'il y ait davantage de
transparence sur la collecte des données
leur utilisation le choix des données
une autre possibilité que l'on porte les
verts c'est d'interdire les aztèques
donc tout ce qui concerne la publicité
avec reconnaissance des données et du
profil de visiter l'utilisateur pour
cibler des publicités
on voit maintenant qu'il ya une tendance
de certains publicité à retirer leurs
marques de plateformes comme facebook
parce qu'ils ne veulent pas être
associés à paraître sur la même page que
des propos et nous ça a été le cas
d'ailleurs donald trump
aussi il ya eu ce problème de retrait de
la de de la publicité de deux de ses
comptes
alors finalement est ce que ça ne donne
pas un peu raison que cet épisode
américain à une europe ce qui l a
produit un digital
acte 2 digital acte d'ailleurs pour
encadrer les dérives des contenus est-ce
que ça n'est pas une démarche du coup
légitime et oui tout à fait l'europe
veut affirmer sa souveraineté dans la
maîtrise des défis du numérique ils sont
de plusieurs ordres
le texte sur la digital services act
traite plutôt de cette partie les
contenus illicites
les grands principes qui doivent réguler
ces outils numériques
et puis le dj seule marque et actes
c'est plutôt la question de la
concurrence et de la compétitivité on
voit bien qu'on est piégé dans un
système où plus on est gros
quand on est une plateforme numérique
plus on maîtrise ses clients donc on
devient encore plus gros on absorbe les
petits qui pourrait émerger ce qui
empêche une véritable concurrence de se
mettre en place c'est l'article manque
d'ardeur zebina dit j'ai embauché des
gens pour modérer il ya treize mille
personnes qui modère les contenus alors
sur la mode sur cette question de la
modération il ya la question de
l'encadrement légal
c'est important après il ya un défi sur
la vitesse d'exécution et c'est là que
nos avis sont un petit peu différent
nous pensons qu'il est important de
protéger notamment quand les contenus
sont particulièrement dangereux donc
terrorisme et ne paie de pornographique
n'est contenu
qu'ils sont porteurs de vraiment de
danger en soi est plutôt exigé le
retrait tout de suite et prendre le
temps des vérifications et corrigé airs
et réédité le contenu si nécessaire
plutôt que d'attendre une décision
judiciaire qui serait longue et la
novation c'est aussi le caractère
transfrontalier de l'injonction puisque
souvent par exemple une un contenu
dangereux peut être vu dans un pays mais
la plateforme être hébergés dans un
autre pays européen et donc dans le cas
des retraits des contenus terroristes on
a pris cette décision
ça a été approuvé dans notre commission
libe et bientôt au parlement européen
nous retrouverons le débat pour le
retrait des contenus haineux ou
illicites
on voit efficacité versus sécurité
juridique
il faut clairement que plus l'outil
d'encadrement est puissant plus le
contre-pouvoir à la surveillance du
respect des libertés individuelles soit
assuré dans le même temps sur la
question de délai on est d'accord donc
le fait que les plateformes puisse
retirer un contenu puis qu'il y ait une
confirmation juridiques judiciaires
pardon de la non-conformité avec
injonction de retraités définitivement
le contenu ou de leur maître si voilà
s'il s'avère que ce n'était pas un
contenu problématique ici on parle du
terrorisme on peut parler aussi d'autres
types de contenus dans le cas du
terrorisme ce qui nous pose réellement
problème c'est que l'état donc dans le
cadre de la coopération transfrontalière
sera chargé de définir l'autorité
compétente pour nous ça doit être
l'autorité judiciaire ça ne peut pas
être une autorité publique
un cabinet ministériel par exemple parce
qu'on voit dans les pays où il ya un
recul de l'état de droit par prenons la
hongrie prenons la pologne où pourraient
recevoir en tant que belge en tant que
français une injonction du gouvernement
hongrois ou polonais de retirer un
certain type de contenu au nom de la
lutte contre le terrorisme au nom de
contenus terroristes même si la belgique
où la france a estimé qu'il ne s'agit
pas de comptes utérus et quelles sont
les dérives pour les droits fondamentaux
là c'est précisément que si ça va à
l'encontre des intérêts de la pologne de
la hongrie dans un contexte de recul de
l'état de droit edd et d'autoritarisme
et bien des communautés lgbt cuit pour
est un moment donné des opposants
politiques pourraient un moment donné
être concernées et c'est là que les
garde-fous doivent être beaucoup plus
solide que la proposition qui est sur la
table alors je voudrais rappeler que sur
ce texte tel qu'il est proposé
maintenant des gars de fonds a été mis
pour les états membres qui sont sous
procédure de l'article 7
un bilan sera établi après un an d'une
part deux ans de mise en oeuvre
donc votre préoccupation a été prise en
compte peut-être pas suffisamment pour
vous mais clairement la question des
états membres qui ne respectent plus
l'état de droit c'est-à-dire
l'indépendance de la justice en
l'occurrence pose problème dans toute la
législation européenne c'est vrai c'est
vrai pour les pays où l'article 7 est
enclenchée mais combien de temps ça a
pris à la commission européenne pour
qu'on y arrive
et donc ce sont les pires cas de figure
aujourd'hui mais il ya quand même aussi
une tendance à avoir d'abord des
définitions différentes de ce qu'est le
terrorisme entre nos états membres et
puis on voit aussi en france par
ailleurs qu'il y à une évolution du
discours par rapport à une forme
sécuritaire et un certain type de
d'information qui je ne dis pas que
c'est le cas aujourd'hui
mais les dérives sont possibles et on
estime que les garde-fous actuelle en
termes de droits fondamentaux ne sont
pas suffisants et dans ceux digital un
service actes il est prévu que les
plateformes doivent réagir aux
notifications en effet dans le contenu
illicite par les autorités
administratives ou judiciaires et ça
vous êtes d'accord lait toutes les deux
là dessus mais sans obligation clair de
retrait alors c'est quand même très
limité fabienne keller alors ça fera
l'objet du débat c'est une proposition
de de la commission si les ronces et les
contenus sont illicites c'est à dire
qu'il vous permettrait une procédure
judiciaire s'il était enfin par leur
nature
on voit pas pourquoi on
ne demanderait pas leur leur retrait on
nous débattrons aussi de l'harmonisation
de la définition de ces contenus
illicites pour l'instant il est prévu
effectivement que c'est les autorités
nationales pour le terrorisme par contre
le texte intègre la définition des
contenus terroristes et en france pour
ce cas là c'est une plateforme
indépendante de l'état indépendante du
gouvernement et qui est sous l'autorité
de la police et de la gendarmerie
judiciaire de la partie judiciaire de
notre enfin donc dû du ministère de la
justice de manière justement à garantir
cette indépendance et son impact quand
même ce qui est ambigu c'est que s'il ya
manquement pour une de ces grosses
plates-formes bien sûr qu'ils aient
révélé les sanctions pécuniaires peuvent
aller jusqu'à 6% du chiffre d'affaires
annuel de la plateforme en question ce
qui al'air beaucoup simplement en effet
il ya beaucoup de volonté mais très peu
de contraintes pour les plateformes
alors est-ce qu'on est ce que cette
sanction financière elle et elle est
seulement réaliste est ce qu on
l'appliquera jamais elle est pour les
grandes parfois qui ont des moyens
derrière de retirer du contenu deux fois
la dose de faire le travail qu'on leur
demande par contre pour les plus petites
plates formes qu'on veut encourager
puisqu'on veut davantage de diversité
diversification des plateformes pour
casser le monopole des gars femmes et ce
texte là ne céderai digital c'est un
problème parce qu'il ne répond pas à la
problématique du monopole sur la
question spécifique du terrorisme la ce
à quoi nous on se heurte c'est
effectivement l'injonction de retrait
qui est si elle n'est pas mise en oeuvre
peut apporter et peut entraîner une
amende ce qui est problématique pour les
plus petites plateformes telles que
c'est formulé aujourd'hui dans le texte
par contre il faut aussi qu en
corollaire est un renforcement des
moyens judiciaires et de police pour que
tous ce travail puisse être mené par des
ressources humaines qu'il y ait des gens
d'aller à l'algorithme j'ai choisi
nationale est votre idée
10 et qui est vraiment les moyens dans
les mains de la justice pour faire ce
travail là et c'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui dans nos différents états
membres et qu'ensuite il y ait ce suivi
avec mise à l'amendé effective
s'il n'ya pas de suivi qui est fait par
les patrons voilà avec le digital
services act un débat européen mais
l'allemagne en 2010 elle s'est déjà
dotée indus loi obligeant les réseaux
sociaux à retirer dans les 24 heures et
là il ya un délai assez rapide un
contenu haineux on a là un petit peu
parlé avant la france propose elle un
abonnement en anticipant le digital
services ac deux pays qui régule dans
leur coin en amont c'est c'est efficace
ces deux pays qui ont vécu en leur sein
des attentats des événements extrêmement
violent qui les ont conduits à souhaiter
voilà s'organiser tout de suite alors 24
heures c'est rapide et scellant à la
fois parce qu'un contenu au bout de 24
heures il il est déjà vu dans le texte
sur le terrorisme c'est une heure pour
éviter qu'ils un contenu dangereux il
est souvent très viral
il se diffuse très vite alors regardons
les choses de manière positive
c'est déjà deux expériences
d'organisation judiciaire qui pourrait
voilà être connue des autres états
membres pour voir comment on peut
démarrer un travail a fait polémique
alors là je n'évoque pas la loi via
qu'il y avait une partie entier
constitutionnel mais la plateforme
pharos par laquelle n'importe qui peut
dire qu'il a vu un contenu terroristes
on a un début d'expérience mans mais en
général on espère mettre en place ces
digital acte débute 2022
au vu des mouvements populistes la
multiplication des fake news notamment
sur la pandémie
ça paraît loin ça paraît loin c'est le
processus législatif mais ce qui est
important c'est d'éviter la
fragmentation et des règles disparate en
fonction des étapes parce que le digital
par définition n'a pas de frontières et
donc un il faut que les règles soient
claires pour les plateformes sur le
marché européen pour l'ensemble des pays
européens idéal
il faudrait une régulation
internationale pour encadrer l'action de
ces plateformes du numérique pour que
les règles soient communes à tous et
appliquées dans tous les pays
le chemin paraît compliqué au niveau
international et donc au niveau européen
et l'essentiel de régulier de mettre un
cadre effectivement le plus vite sera le
mieux parce qu'on sait que les
conséquence notamment d'effets que news
sont dévastatrices
merci à vous d'avoir très bien illustré
ce débat merci vous restez sur nos
antennes pour la suite des programmes
[Musique]